hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast deciphering the
complexities of neuro degeneration and
neuro inflammation with gene expression
profiling presented by Kelly Miller
application scientist nano string
technologies incorporated I'm Alexis
Krause of laberd's and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's and
sponsored by nano string technologies
for more information about our sponsor
please visit WWE
the for we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen dr. Miller will be responding to
your questions via email if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2018
please join me and jelton welcoming dr.
Kelly Miller I will now turn the
presentation over to her
good morning everyone and thank you for
joining our webinar today really excited
to go over some of the content here
before I get started I would like to
remind you that this is an interactive
webinar so there's a Q&A box on the
right-hand side definitely feel free to
ask questions throughout the
presentation and we'll try to answer
them as quickly as we can and we can
also answer at the end and get some
feedback as we go along so this webinar
is on deciphering the complexities of
nerve degeneration and neuro
inflammation with gene expression
profiling and I'm Kyle Downey I'm a
product manager at nano string and I'd
like to introduce you to Kelly Miller
who's going to give the talk today she
has a PhD in biomedical science from the
University of Florida after that she did
her postdoc at sherry Hayes Medical
University in Germany she was a group
sorry a research scientist at UPenn
Center for nerds generative disease
research and most recently she joined
nano sharing as a field application
scientist so Kelly's takeaway thanks so
much for that introduction Kyle as
mentioned prior to joining nano string I
was an academic neuroscience researcher
myself so I'm really very excited to be
introducing the Anna strands first
neuroscience specific products in this
webinar are neuropathology and
neuroinflammation gene expression panels
so I'm going to spend the next 40
minutes or so giving an overview of how
manna string technology works
demonstrating performance of the
platform and relevant sample types
describing our new panel contents in the
neuroscience field and sharing some
really interesting data generated using
that neuropathology panel so I hope that
by the end of the presentation you have
a solid understanding of how the
technology works and it's suited to your
particular samples and therefore how you
can use these tools that I'll be
presenting today to move your own
studies forward assistive ministering
technology lies in the encounter
instruments combined with a unique
barcoding chemistry that together allow
for the simultaneous digital
quantification of up to 800 targets in a
given sample
the mana string started as an RNA
company providing solutions for gene
expression profiling but the technology
has been adapted to allow for expanded
applications that include not only mRNA
profiling but also micro RNA fusion gene
detection DNA profiling with
applications like copy number variation
single nucleotide variant detection and
even protein analysis and this happens
all on the same instrument with the same
readout using the same chemistry we
offer hardware solutions for both
investigational and clinical use with
three different instrument options and
also as they've suited for any type of
project whether you aim for targeted
discovery using one of our pre curated
gene expression panels multi analyte
analysis with our 3d biology assays
which allow you to simultaneously
profile any combination of RNA DNA and
protein in a given sample or if you want
to perform sample multiplexing with our
plex set assays that are what assays
you're using we utilize one core
chemistry and the basis for these
applications lies in simple base pairing
the platform is measuring individual
nucleic acid molecules hybridize the
fluorescent barcodes allowing you to
perform single or multi analyte analysis
or even morphology driven profiling with
our new digital spatial profiling
application which is our latest
initiative to utilize the encounter
chemistry to extend our profiling
capabilities to fixed issues in a
spatially resolved manner and this is
technology that's sure to prove
exceptionally useful in the field of
neuroscience in particular second our
pre curated gene expression panels I'd
like to go ahead and introduce both our
neuroinflammation pathology panels so
you can begin to understand what types
of questions you can address in your
samples using these tools so I'll go
through and review the content and the
important features of both panels start
the neuropathology panel here we've
designed a panel for human and one for
mouse h contains 770 target genes
including 10 reference genes that were
carefully chosen by taking into account
the stability of expression across a
wide range of neuro pathological
conditions
we also build in a series of positive
and negative controls into every assay
on top of the 770 mentioned genes and
for analysis purposes we provide
functionally annotated gene lists for
all of the content which is broken down
into six fundamental themes intended to
really draw the address key topics in
neurodegenerative disease research
including neurotransmission neuron glia
interactions neuroplasticity structural
integrity nor inflammation and
metabolism so in total this content
covers 23 different pathways and
processes and it was selected by
reviewing current literature in this
field and also consulting with
researchers at a variety of academic
institutions biotech and pharmaceutical
companies and finally a messaging
content there are also cell
type-specific gene signatures built in
to allow for cell profiling during the
data analysis time you can see the six
themes that I just mentioned broken down
further and if you look at the
annotation column over towards the right
you'll see a more detailed description
of categorical content including the
number of genes representing each
particular pathway or function one
category I want to point out is neuro
inflammation which is a process that's
highly relevant for neurodegenerative
diseases like Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's but is also relevant for
nearly all neuro pathological conditions
so you can see on the right hand side
that there are nearly 100 genes devoted
just to monitoring the functional state
of microglia as well as another
approximately 50 cytokines that are all
profiled on this panel also terms of
neuro inflammation what's not listed
there are a number of astra static genes
that have been included which allow for
the monitoring of astra static responses
as well and here you can see a table
that I took from one of Michael's
Iranians reviews describing different
functional categories of genes modulated
by reactive astrocytes and I've
highlighted those genes that are covered
by this panel in bold so overall you can
see that there is very good coverage of
mechanisms underlying your inflammatory
processes even though this panel more
broadly covers neurodegenerative disease
pathways much more so than our neuro
inflammation panel another category I
want to highlight just below neuron for
me
Shanna's metabolism which includes
nearly 50 genes devoted to monitoring
the unfolded protein response almost a
hundred for oxidative stress in more
than 34 apology which could prove really
valuable for say Parkinson's research
among others asked feature of the panel
that I want to point out is the cell
type profiling feature here you can see
a few key neural cell types and to the
right you see genes whose expression has
been empirically determined to be
largely specific to those certain neural
cell populations so our n solver
advanced analysis software module we use
these genes to measure the abundance of
these cell types or their reactivity in
the case of say activated activated
astrocytes for example that's allowing
you to assess cell specific enrichment
in your heterogeneous samples moving on
to the neuro inflammation panel you can
see that this panel is also designed for
both human and mouse and also targets
770 genes which includes 13 reference
genes and again this panel comes with a
fully annotated gene list and the
content is broken down in this case into
three core themes that were selected to
allow for analysis of key aspects of
neuro-immune interactions and also
comprehensively evaluate pathways and
processes that are associated with no
inflammation so in total the content
covers 23 different pathways and
includes the cell type-specific gene
signatures for 19 different cell types
the content here is broken down to cover
immunity and inflammation including both
adaptive and innate immune responses
with a total of nearly 275 jeans devoted
to those processes more than a hundred
genes devoted to cytokine signaling 185
to microbial activation and more than a
hundred to inflammatory signaling in the
neurobiology and neuropathology section
you can see the panel covers neuron and
the adventure site and astrocyte
function as well with eighty-one genes
devoted to neurons 27 for Legos and 55
specific for astrocytes among of course
the other categories listed here and
finally you can see we have genes
covering metabolism and cell stress
which include more than 200 targets
I put the neural pathology panels Excel
profile feature is also included in this
panel with signatures built in for the
five neural cell types and 14 peripheral
immune cell types and if you're
interested in learning more about how
these signatures are developed and how
they work we can check out this
publication from our team that we've
reviewed the panel content and benefits
I want to share some performance data
that I think illustrates a point in it
in the beginning so this platform is
especially well suited to handle
neuroscience samples which often is just
a small sample data from sorted cell
populations or IPS c-drive neurons laser
capture samples or micro dissected mouse
brain regions for example and also from
post-mortem human brain tissue that's
not only six but often paraffin-embedded
and therefore highly degraded so since
there aren't really a lot of robust
solutions for some of these samples nano
string offers the possibility to gain a
lot of otherwise potentially
unattainable information first example I
have here it's from a 2012 nature
medicine paper and here they're
demonstrating the reproducibility
obtained from very poor quality FFPE
samples if you're familiar with bio
analyze the traces you can see that the
quality of example is really really bad
and they used as low as 25 milligram
input and yet you can see in the graph
on the left inter coil it replicates all
with our square values of 5.99
specifically each point on the graph
represents the correlation from an
independent pair of samples showing that
the system is highly reproducible even
when working with this degraded sample
next example also focuses on 6 samples
but these are formalin-fixed cells that
would process for facts so on the top
and the bioanalyzer traces you can see
the effects of fixation with unfixed
cells on the left and the fixed cells on
the right and in this study the author's
compared to PCR and nano string new data
on this slide are the qpcr data and what
we're looking at are the delta CT
between 6 and m6 cells for two different
genes 18s and gap th among three
different cell types so obviously we'd
all like to see a delta CT of 0
to be sure that our technical procedures
weren't impacting our biological readout
but in this case you can see that in
five of six instances fixation LEDs with
significant difference in gene
expression as measured by the qpcr nice
figures they show the Nano string
results and you can see firstly that
they've multiplexed several genes and on
the left you see the actual data counts
for each gene compared between the fixed
and unfixed cells with minimal
differences and on the right you can see
that there's a correspondingly high
correlation between counts and the
authors concluded in this study that
nano strings are not qPCR proved equally
efficient in profiling this fixed and on
fixed samples only this data was
generated using our neuron pathology
gene expression panel the human panel
and it showed similar reproducibility
between fresh and FFPE tissues so in
these scatter plots you're seeing the
correlation between fresh frozen and
FFPE brain tissue taken at autopsy from
two different patients and you'll see
that there's an excellent correlation
between the fresh and FFPE samples and
what's even more impressive about those
r-squared values is that the fresh and
FFP material were taken from opposite
brain hemispheres which certainly
introduces variability in gene
expression already so these values are
really quite good and below this you can
see the counts per gene from a randomly
selected subset of targets on the panel
demonstrating what we saw in that
previous study which is that counts are
consistent between samples or
preservation methods the last kind of
performance data I want to show you
speaks to sample flexibility because
nano string doesn't require
amplification or enzymes you can work
with whole RNA or directly with cell
lysis and this slide shows how the data
compare between 40 nano grams of total
RNA and 4,000 lifestyles and you can see
that the live dates performed equally
well and his evidence from the
literature where they make a similar
comparison using either 100 nanograms
total RNA or 10,000 live cells and here
they compare data from multiple donors
at different time points and in all
cases there was a very high correlation
between results obtained really you know
again just demonstrating that
technology presents a viable option for
samples that consist of precious low
yield cells in which maybe you don't
want to or can't extract RNA or projects
in which the sample number may make RNA
isolation impractical here's a similar
comparison showing here in this case
FFPE lysate performance for brain
samples so this includes both purified
RNA from FFPE in green and crude FFPE
light state and orange both compared
then to purified RNA from fresh frozen
material and this really shows again
this equivalent performance of the FFPE
RNA and FFP Eli States I'll just share a
couple more pieces of performance data
that were generated using our
neuropathology panel the first thing
considering common sample types because
it's platform is so amenable to FFP we
expect a lot of translational studies
that could serve to connect the data
obtained in the past from studies and
animal models on over to the human
setting and for this purpose postmortem
FFP tissue is certainly the most readily
available human brain material so I
already showed you earlier the excellent
performance of FFP material compared to
fresh frozen using the neural path panel
and here we wanted to test the
performance of these samples in terms of
post-mortem interval so in this heat map
of raw data which is shown as data
counts you can see that an unbiased
clustering approach demonstrates that
all samples performed well and equally
independent of the post-mortem interval
and that's really most evident when you
look at the grouping at the top and you
see that these samples aren't clustering
based on the PMI so samples with a PMI
greater than 35 hours can be found right
next to samples that have a PMI of 6 to
10 hours for example another important
sample quality issue that we wanted to
address is the performance of blood
samples on the neuropathology panel so
unlike the neuroinflammation panel which
has gene content for a peripheral immune
cells the neuropathology panel is of
course more strictly CNS focused and
therefore we wanted to assess whether a
substantial proportion of genes on the
panel are detectable in blood and as you
can see in the heat map again showing
raw data in which we profound blood from
controlled
from patients with frontotemporal
dementia most targets were detected in
robust range which you can see shown in
orange and overall about sixty to eighty
percent of all targets were detectable
confirming that this panel is reasonable
for studies in which one might want to
assess blood brain correlates for
example and now just before I move on to
share some of the biology and covered
with this panel I want to take a minute
to acknowledge our collaborators who
worked with our garments that I'll be
mentioning and who provided the samples
and are continuing to pursue these
studies all data you'll see today we're
generated using samples obtained from
the University of Pennsylvania Center
for neurodegenerative disease research
which is led by Virginia Lee and John
Trojan offski and our partners in these
studies include Stephan Procop Viviana
Frontierland how he and unrolls do so
obviously we're very grateful for the
chance to work with all of them both
that we use to generate the data that
you'll see today include both Mouse and
human material for the mouse studies we
work with tissue from 5xf ad mice all
from the human studies we profile
samples that came from Alzheimer's
Parkinson's and FTD patients and in all
cases we used purified RNA and while the
mouse tissue was fresh frozen all of the
human data I'll share were generated
using FFP a tissue also all of the data
you'll see here were generated using our
n sama advanced analysis software and
again all samples were run in either the
mouse or the human or a pathology panel
so first I want to share some findings
uncovered when we analyzed whole tissue
samples from the five x fa d mice which
are a common ad mouse model again these
figures were generated using our n
Pomerance analysis module and here you
can see a couple examples of gene set
specific heat maps generated with
unbiased clustering that show a clear
segregation expression patterns in the
5x fa d mice compared to controls so on
the left you can see that genes
associated with otology are elevated in
the disease setting and on the right you
can appreciate increased expression of
genes associated with microglial
activation which all make a lot of sense
given
we know in the field about this model
and look at the cell profiling feature
and focus on the micro real score in
particular you can see that this
analysis demonstrates an enrichment in
microglia that's right in line with what
we see in that heat map being at other
cell profiling scores here you can see a
lower neuron score and disease mice
which corresponds really nicely to the
known neuronal loss that occurs in this
mouth line we compared pathology related
genetic changes in the mouse model to
the human disease we found similar
pathways affected such as vesicular
trafficking which you can see on the
right is reduced in av mice compared to
controls and also in hippocampal
specimens from high aging patients which
you see on the far left hand side
looking more closely at Dennis data is
generated from the human samples here
you can see a heat map of the entire 770
gene set on the left and a blow-up of
the outlined area to the right and if
you look at the order of the samples and
the corresponding gene expression you
can see that this particular subset of
genes undergoes to progressive decrease
in expression that corresponds to
increased disease severity with controls
at the top working down through low
intermediate ad cases to high ad cases
and these were classified using ABC
criteria and I think that this data
really nicely demonstrates that the
content on this panel is relevant for
profiling your degeneration and it's
really targeting pathways and processes
that are changing and disease an
illustration of that point is being here
so here we're looking at the pathways
scores produced in M solver and we found
a conserved disturbance and
neurotransmission across
neurotransmitter response synthesis
storage and release in high 80 cases
again with progressive changes evident
in accordance with disease severity so
this was really very interesting and
also reassuring in terms of detecting
changes that really make sense and to
which we can assign some biological
meaning here you can see two plots for
mouse models in which the animal model
is mimicking the changes we see in the
human samples
all of these graphs were looking at
transmitter response and we have to take
and in the center you can see reduced
scores for five XF [ __ ] that were
injected with human tau and therefore
have more robust pathology than
uninjected 5x SAT nice and on the right
we again see that in the disease setting
compared to control genes associated
with no transmission are again reduced
so overall this data shows us that these
changes were observing or progressive
and most importantly that some of these
very important changes that we see
happening in the human brain are also
occurring in our animal models which is
really critical validation of these
model systems so here looking at cell
profiling scores in human aging we can
see something similar to what we saw in
the 5x FA demise which is that microglia
and astrocytes are enriched in
association with high AD and that neuron
loss is occurring in the most severe
cases and here you can see that this
microglial activation that we've
detected genetically corresponds nicely
to what was found using
immunohistochemistry network across
diseases and here we're comparing human
aging hippocampus to hippocampus from
parkinson's patients at a late stage of
disease we can see some alterations that
are conserved across different diseases
as compared to the control patient so in
this case you can see on the left that
the unfolded protein response which is
obviously important for maintaining
Proteus thesis is reduced in both ad and
PD while on the right you can see that
chromatin modification seems to be
elevated in both conditions highlighting
some shared mechanisms that may be
important for pathogenesis and treatment
across multiple neurodegenerative
conditions here as I also showed you in
the context of Alzheimer's we profile
midbrain specimens from Parkinson's
patients and controls and you see in
these heat maps that specific subsets of
genes are clearly differentially
expressed in PD patients versus controls
so on the left you can see a set of
genes upregulated in PD cases well on
the right you see targets that are
reduced in the PD setting so again this
highlights that the curated content on
the panel is capturing disease related
changes and can really provide insight
into disease mechanism finally here you
can see with an unbiased clustering
approach in the PD midbrain there are
clear differences in expression of genes
associated with key pathways of
transmitter release and vesicle
trafficking suggesting deficits and
neurotransmission which is well in line
with what we know about the pathogenesis
and progression of PD so this is the
last of the data that I'm going to share
I just wanted to give a glimpse of what
we've explored in this rich sample pool
of ad PD and mal samples that we
obtained from our collaborators at Penn
obviously there are much more in-depth
analyses yet to be performed and that's
what the researchers at Penn will
continue working on so we're certainly
very excited to see the final
conclusions of their studies of this
presentation you've seen that nano
string shows robust performance on a
variety of sample types including
post-mortem human tissue and that using
our pre curated gene content you can
rapidly identify biology that's
differentiating normal samples whether
it's patient or mal examples from those
of diseased patients or mice using our
advanced analysis software
moreover we discovered conserved changes
in human and mouse samples demonstrating
that these panels really enable a
seamless translational research with
reproducible results and another great
feature is the integrated self signature
content and analysis capabilities that
enable that cell type profiling and
lastly this panel content is designed to
cover neurodegenerative diseases broadly
which really enables discovery of
targetable biology that's consistent and
that's relevant across multiple disease
types so I hope that this data and
information that I've shared has helped
you to envision how you can best address
your research questions and also get the
most information from your samples and
so we'd love to see what you all can
discover using these panels so we're
offering a grant contest that will award
five winners with 24 reactions of either
the neuropathology gene expression panel
or the neuro inflammation panel the
deadline for submission is March 16th so
I encourage you to go to our website and
submit your application
having demonstrated the type of
interesting biological insight that can
be gained using these panels in our
platform I just want to return again to
highlight the simplicity and ease by
which one can acquire this data no
matter what assays you're using we're
relying on simple base pairing for
single or multi analyte analysis for
morphology driven profiling and this is
simplicity underlying these applications
that lends itself so well to
translational research because it's
simply hybridization based gene
expression analysis is performed without
any amplification cDNA synthesis or use
of enzymes and therefore the system is
really very tolerant of poor quality
material or typically hard to profile
material like FFPE for example making it
really feasible to translate your data
from say animal models to post-mortem
human tissue as you just saw the
technology is also highly reproducible
which again is tied to the fact that
there is no amplification bias or
reliance upon enzymes and also due to
the multiplexing capability nano string
is ideal for pathway analysis such as
you saw in that data today which really
facilitates a more holistic approach to
analysis and finally the workflow is
really simple so whether you're
analyzing a few or many hundreds of
targets due to the fact that there's
minimal hands-on manipulation which
certainly also contributes to the
precision and reliability amela close by
announcing an exciting program that will
be available soon which is our digital
spatial profiling technology access
program which will bring the
advancements of DSP to your project with
the possibility of running samples in
our labs in Seattle before the
instrument is available on the market
this technology allows you to quantify
multiple protein targets simultaneously
on FFP tissue sections on a side in a
completely non-destructive manner so it
provides you with quantitative digital
spatial information and we'll be
launching our neuro protein panel in
April and we'll start accepting projects
at that time and for more information
about that program you can email tasks
at Nanjing comm the address is shown
here on the screen and of course please
don't forget to go to our website and
you're on your science grant
applications so with that I'll close and
thank you all for your attention
great Thank You Kelly those really good
information and there's a lot of content
to unpack so really appreciate you
taking the time to to go through all
those I'd like to remind everyone in the
audience that again this is an
interactive session so we'd really like
to see if you have any questions that
you'd like to ask Kelly or if anything
that has come up that you'd like a
little bit more information about so go
ahead and send any of those into the Q&A
box and I'll go ahead and review those
looks like there's a couple of good ones
that have come in so far so kelly first
one that we'll ask for you this is a
good question so how much RNA is
required for the Nano string assay so
the RNA input really depends on your
sample type and what genes are looking
at or which panel you're working with
but in general the range is anywhere
from twenty five nanograms to three
hundred nanogram i would say our
standard input for these neuro panels is
fifty to a hundred and I can say already
that I've seen really robust counts
coming off of these sample types on
these panels so um you know for for a
very you know in a very general sense I
would say 50 nanogram is a great
starting point okay and another question
kind of related how does the Nano string
as they perform on CSF as a sample type
so CFS is definitely definitely works on
this platform we have a publication on
our web site profiling micro RNA and CSF
it worked great we haven't run it
specifically on the neuro panel but
again in terms of you know input for CSF
that's something that you would want to
optimize you know on a
project-by-project basis okay great all
right another one here
can you describe in more detail how the
cell profiling feature works with this
panel
yeah sure so this self profiling feature
and you know if you're interested in
this I would again encourage you and to
check out that publication by by our
team the first authors Patrick Danna
hair and and there he describes the
method that's used to measure the
abundance of these cell populations so
basically it quantified cell populations
using marker genes that are expressed
stabili and specifically in given cell
types so these marker genes will act as
reference genes specific to those
individual cell types and they should
only be expressed in that particular
cell type at the same level in each cell
so our advanced analysis software will
perform all of that scoring for you and
of course it's taking into consideration
those things that I just mentioned
perfect thank you and definitely want to
remind everyone again you can always add
your questions to the queue okay another
question I came in how were the genes in
this panel selected yes so for both of
these panels the genes were selected
after you know really careful review of
the literature what's going on this
field currently and then really going
out and talking to researchers as they
said you know we reached out to people
not only in academia but also in biotech
and pharma companies researched relevant
databases and you know and known known
data that's online to really pull out
the most relevant information for you
know in the case of the neuropathology
panel for all of the common
neurodegenerative diseases and really
try and find the content that is
specifically relevant and well-suited to
what seems to be going on in these
diseases and I think that was really the
message that comes across in this data
as we start to look at it you know it
was true for the mouse samples for the
ad for the PD samples that we can really
segregate these samples the disease
cases from the control and we can really
pull out
pathways and processes that are being
affected in disease so I think in that
regard we really really accomplished
that goal
perfect and here's a good question so
can the gene content be customized if
someone has a favorite gene can they add
it in yeah absolutely both of these
panels and you can add up to 30 genes to
both of these panels you can customize
in that regard obviously and you can
build completely custom panels at Nanna
string but if you want to work with the
content on these panels and just need to
add in a few of your favorites or
targets that may not be there that are
particularly important for your project
then you can just add those on and you
can profile a total of up to 800 gene
perfect and another question on the self
profiling so the neuroinflammation panel
has the same cell profiling feature is
it any different yeah it absolutely has
the same features but in addition to the
5 CMS specific cell types that are
profiled on the neuropathology panel it
also contains 14 signatures for
peripheral immune cell types so it's
working in the same way but there's a
lot a lot more signatures built in